okay four people joining this livestream
I am back to doing a few live streams
based on my day job which is designing
developing wolfing language so if people
are here for this is this is the
underpinning of what makes the physics
project possible but this is not the
physics project we will actually be
having a live stream about more physics
project and black holes and things at
4:00 p.m. Eastern actually Jose if you
happen to be available for that you'd be
most welcome
um okay there okay so we are launching
into this is a live stream alright let's
get to work here okay
first item email threat analysis so this
is can we see some examples of this is
this some I mean this is how good is
that okay so is the thread graph
realistic look at that example linked
for version 12 I think for why not if
that the graph is not gonna have huge
information other than this this graph
you are creating in this example has
more than just message IDs but I think
if you want to basically develop at red
graph element it's just gonna be message
IDs and links and anything else is gonna
be derived from that graph but so the
message IDs okay so I mean this is maybe
very very scary but I could try doing
this actually on my email um ah
none of those elements are implemented
now they're just produced
I see so okay so fine so the question is
really in I mean first of all is email a
graph or a hyper graph can somebody
explain that to me I mean what is a
thread
so in other words if I were to look at
my email which I'm not about to pull up
right now but but Tim um it's a tree one
single thread is a tree I don't believe
you I mean in other words I think what's
what's some okay let me let me
understand what a thread is a thread is
linked by the message ID of replies is
that correct and you yes but you
typically reply to one email so there is
only one email that your new email is a
reply to you may have content from other
emails copied but that doesn't count at
the end your new email has a message ID
and it's a reply to of a single message
I the email I see but so when you get a
message which combines multiple
preceding messages those are not being
part of the thread the thread represents
a is a thread that just goes initial
message with a message ID and what about
when people forward that message to you
I don't think this is right how does
forwarding work forwarding doesn't show
up in there in the thread graph anyways
that below creates well that creates a
new tree of its own that's that's the
beginning of a new threat it's not a
reply to of anything
okay but but so the threading um of you
know in like Apple Mail or something
what how is the threading working there
this is somebody who else is is is shown
on this Sean I can't yet here okay so
can somebody answer that how does it
work I mean in existing mailers how does
it thread I think it's exactly what
shadi said everything is chained
together with actual replies to each
other if you forward something it's
gonna show if there's a new email in the
mail okay which is not great but I mean
at least we let's at least reproduce
okay so you're saying what what is the
analog of this four thread cam what
what's that
analogous to what other property is that
analogous to um so if I look for what
should I be looking at mail what what is
the where should I look to get our
listeners I would look at the exam
documentation there no no no I'm not
asking for that I'm asking for I'm
asking for what are the import elements
right for EM box okay that is operable
to the thread graph is going to be made
up with reply T message ID in message
ready when you have a count there is
there another count thing the others a
message count here sure each individual
email
count is the number of those trees that
you have from the threat threat graph
which when you open an email client it
means how many chunks of threats how
many items do you see in your embed
inbox that you're looking at so when I
say I mean like right now my inbox says
1640 three messages okay
are those the if I went and counted you
know I have threading turned on if I
went and counted that um uh would um
would that be the number of top-level
threads or is that the number of
messages total typically its message
message count total number of messages
individuals are not the number of
threads right so for example I mean in
principle if we have this all running so
this is my email inbox tracker right so
in principle I could have another piece
to my inbox tracker that gives not only
my total messages but also my total
threads correct and that's what you're
proposing thread count does yep okay
thread email count in each of those
threads how many emails do you have
that's the right name for it
sure I mean
well yeah mess message count we had
message count as a total number of
messages right and this graduation thing
okay so that's the thing that you had
shown here which is a time line plot of
these threads that's an interesting plot
I've never seen that plot I mean I could
make that plot for my email I'd like to
see what it looks like um
you
although it's a very weird I mean again
that's an association right so I mean
these should end with rules or something
duration rules if it's going to be that
association of association of list of
people involved in the thread but people
can
I'm so confused here this is either yes
I guess some food for thought more than
actual design proposals I I guess the
key thing the key element here is gonna
be the threat graph and once we have the
graph all of those other things are easy
to drive and derive from the graph
I understand but let's let's understand
what I mean I thought about this like
probably five times over the last twenty
years of what really is the structure of
an email conversation and I don't think
it's what you're describing because I
think for example you could be
responding to a message that one model
is there is a message there's a replied
as a reply there's a reply it's a linear
thing right but somebody else could
reply somebody a different person could
reply and they could start a separate
branch in the tree right if you scroll
up the trees that we had on see that
first one exactly that that's the
scenario you're explaining is where
somebody replies to something which is
8:00 at a different place in that thread
right so in a typical mailer what is
actually shown is a typical mailer
taking the the time plot boy this
reminds me of the physics project in a
kind of bizarre way because I mean each
one of these things there are two
notions of time there's a causal time
which is the sequence you know what
message can only happen after some other
Musset measures which happened and there
is the actual wall clock time of when
the message was received right so this
tree what do you think that a typical
mailer actually displays does it just
take everything in this tree as a big
bucket of stuff and then just order them
in the order of receipt you think that I
think that's what it does yes yes by
date okay so in other words it is the
connected component one connected
component in your graph here corresponds
to one top-level thing in a standard
mailer and then these are ordered by
date correct okay so now what are we
missing in this picture I mean we're
certainly missing anything we're certain
so any forwarding is missed here this is
only replies correct
yes
okay so Peter on our live stream is
pointing out that in the RFC for this
there is a references header which has
an in reply too right so the in reply to
is what is the message ID that is being
kept in your thread threading thing is
that correct yes so is there any
references that's an element okay so
what is the references as the references
other emails that are being referenced
other message IDs not necessarily the in
reply to reference ID yes message ID
okay so that we are not capturing in
this tree correct
so in other words we're capturing the in
reply to threading information but we're
not capturing the references threading
information okay were we to capture the
references threading information we
would have a more general graph I assume
is it even a graph or is it a hyper
graph well it depends on how we think
about it I mean so so okay so what we're
thinking about is you know in reply to
is one so first thing is can we get for
a given message do we have an in reply
to which is the element here that says
what it is in reply to reply to you
message ID which is we're gonna scroll
down
okay all right great so I see referent
reference message ID list okay so we
have exactly these two things okay so
now the question how are we constructing
a graph from this how are we
constructing the threading graph from
this right yep
and so one graph might be um you know we
could say reply to message graph which
would be
let's see in other words that is I'd say
actually the consistent way to do it
would be to call it reply to that's a
list there why is this cold list in this
one not call list
reply to a message ID there's only one
one message that message in that M box
could be a reply to another message so
you get a list corresponding to the
number of emails you have I say okay
fine
okay but this one is for each email
there is a list of the emails to which
it which widget references correct yes
okay so look the obvious thing here will
be reply to a message ID graph which
would be basically the graph of the you
know given a message that will be the
graph derived from the mbox starting
from a given message
oh I see that's that's for the whole em
box yeah okay although you might want it
anchored to a particular message right
that's a sub-element syntax that we have
below
so either starting from a message or
containing that message we have to
decide which one we can probably just do
one or or we need more syntax okay if we
say reply to a message ID graph that is
at least clear what it is yep because
then we can also say um reference
what that is is a hypergraph is it not
what is that so each each message has a
certain less set of messages that it
references by the way which way does the
directed graph go so when it's a reply
to message ID it should be a directed
graph that goes from the message that is
being replied to to the message that is
replying do you and I agree good so the
route or the first email in that thread
is always the root of that tree fine yep
okay so then this in the case where
there are multiple referenced messages
presumably the messages that are being
referenced should be incoming edges to
the message which is doing the
referencing correct
yep I think this is still it just a
graph unless I'm missing something
um right well because references are
basically gonna have a direction to
every email that was previous the thread
it'll connect all of the messages in the
thread together sorry which one reply to
message ID the the reply to message ID
is just the one being replied to but
then the references will have the entire
thread the starting with the first the
root node and then the reference ID of
the next email and the next email until
you're at the email that you're sending
or your asking which subgraph will it be
so in other words if I what I'm saying
is given a message right it references
certain predecessor messages I mean this
is for those following the physics
project this is a causal graph exactly
sorry too I don't know who in this
meeting is is some is physics I physics
project oriented but it's really funny
boy you know given a new hammer once
these nails everywhere um but this is
basically um
all right so this is saying given a node
which is your current message
this has incoming edges from all
messages that that current message
references yes
um
okay so I think it's just a graph so and
Shawn is it correct that it's always
referencing all previous messages in
that thread
well email clients can pretty much do
whatever they want but that's what it
should be is it the case then that every
but it could reference other stuff so
when has a forwarded message does it get
to be in the references list I can't say
for certain but I highly doubt it so are
you saying basically that the transitive
closure that basically the reference
message ID graph is merely the
transitive closure of the reply to
message ID graph let me be specific so I
mean if I have a if I do this if I make
a path graph of something like this
right
then I could say here I could make a
transitive closure graph of this what a
mess right so in other words what that's
doing is this is did you see what I'm
saying but I don't think that each node
is going to touch everything else right
well but look at what this is doing so
if I save five here for example and I
say vertex labels to automatic okay so
now I too will link to one three will
link to two and yes so so you're saying
that the reference message ID graph so
far as we know in in mailers is simply
this transitive closure graph of so
what's interesting here is they think
that with the reply to message ID graph
it makes sense for the direction to be
from the route down but it seems like
these are referencing back to messages
so it's almost like the errors should be
going the other way maybe
maybe
and of that but I also okay can we
determine for certain what's true about
forwarded messages and whether for
example we are able to potentially
detect those given that we are parsing I
mean we know when there's a forwarded
message yes or no it's only based on
some hint from the subject line there's
nothing good in this what about quoted
constitutes don't we know from quoted
content again quoted content is you know
basically if the client was nice enough
to put an angle bracket at the front of
the line
none of these are completely reliable I
understand that and that the coated
content is the same for reply or reply
to or for the emails or if you just
copy/paste and just manually coat that
piece of text
I mean look part of what we're trying to
do here is you know just like there's
natural language processing there's
natural email processing so to speak and
it's not an exact science and it would
be highly useful to me for example to be
able to see these more complicated
things that involve forwarding and so on
but so look what would what we're
implementing right now is these things
which are essentially deterministically
findable from message headers what we
might imagine in the future is something
that is more heuristic um but what
you're saying here
to read see the issue here
um I kind of am I'm slightly in them and
the mind to say reply to thread count--
yeah making it clear that it's uh you
know that's how we're defining a thread
I like it and maybe reply to thread
grass just to a black establish it there
and all these properties are as opposed
to as opposed to the message ID part of
that thing yes
you know I do think that forwarding adds
a references tag I just tried it hmm
okay that's when I say look at the
thread in Thunderbird it does show it as
a part of that thread and I'm assuming
that it's using references there okay so
that's only going to be something so
imagine the receiving message though
it's not going to have a message with
that message ID in its mbox
only I have the thing that I forward it
from I see so to tag it with a message
ID but but the message ID is like a UID
I mean it's a it's a unique tag albeit
one that I can't resolve if I am only
the forward II so to speak correct
okay well I mean that's okay so that's
an interesting thing which we don't
necessarily have support for is is this
message ID in the sandbox
I mean we and how we definitely do
because you can query by message ID and
if you get back a failure object failure
well dollar failed cuz it's imported I
wish that was a failure object and it
really should be changed to be that but
that's a different discussion yeah we
just wanna break everything in the
process I understand I understand that
that needs to be part of this code
robust application project that
hopefully is going to happen this summer
of handling what to do with different
kinds of error conditions deep inside
code and how to propagate that I'm sure
there's a million same key of course yes
of course there are okay okay so then um
I mean we could put something in here
that is part of the import rather than
just getting a failure there hmm well
okay that's a separate issue okay okay
if we have so you're saying the
reference well okay so that maybe this
becomes then referenced messages graph
[Music]
now since you can identify a particular
message to be the quotes root of that
graph I kind of think well you're trying
to argue that these arrows should
potentially go the other way and I'm not
sure I agree with that I think it's more
consistent to have them be the
contributors to the message that you are
currently looking at yeah I think that
makes sense to you now the other thing
you might want is given a mess
JD what are the outgoing I mean in the
reply to thread graph here given a
message ID is the message that you are
giving message 5 or message 1
in other words if you want to pick out
that connective component of the
threading graph
while you're proposing this is global to
the mbox but then this is when you pick
out a specific um uh you get what I'm
saying when you're picking out a
specific message ID go through one on
this end yes
because if you pick cookie then it would
just be everything subsequent to it oh
right I think there's an argument it
could go the other way around
in other words that that you want to
specify five there and get everything
that contributes to five
right there's boat both ways round are
interesting both the consequent to one
and the precedent to five so to speak
you
so how would we specify that because
that that relates to this message ID
here which is a separate tag and it's
almost like you know source versus
destination this isn't a serious
suggestion but I almost imagine it being
negative message ID that just doesn't
make any sense though it doesn't really
make sense I mean it would be if it was
a if it was a six you know in this case
that's fine but but it isn't you know
unless we could have a wrapper around
the message ID but that's rather
complicated as well I mean what we could
do is something like element comma I
don't know whether we have a syntax like
this but initial aro blah blah blah or
you know final arrow blah blah blah do
we have any precedent for that I mean
this could be an option too oh I see so
we just say initial message oh go ahead
no notice that what we had proposed
there was all the whole thread including
that message ID and I'm wondering if you
could just leave it at that and then do
whatever graph chunking that we need to
say so in other words that you would
take the complete connected component
that contains that node yes that's a
reasonable default I mean I can imagine
taking the sub tree or the or the you
know the feeding entry or that okay
let's do that initially let's do that
just the connected component including
that message okay let's see what else do
we have to figure out here so we've got
reply to thread count reply to thread
graph referenced messages graph or
referencing messages graph but what is
the right thing to say message reference
in graph that the better thing
say and so reply to thread count is the
number of connected components in the
reply to thread graph correct there will
be the number of graphs number of
connected components in the by number of
graphs you mean the number of connected
pieces here yes yes yes because this
thread um you know this thing is in
general a graph with many disconnected
components right correct and okay and
the the in that graph the node labels
are merely the message IDs yes and to
resolve that message ID you have to
separately import it from the inbox with
that message ID specified yeah to get
the message to get other attributes of
that how would you get if I wanted to
get the the from from information with
the same sub sub element specification
so you would say body from to for that
message ID
okay so I say from and then the
message-id so in other words I've got a
piece of code I mean we probably want
some helpful functions at least in the
function repository and possibly more at
least in the function repository that
will for example get you one of these
graphs with a label with a you know a
vertex label that is who the message is
from for example
um right notice that in that example we
had the piece of the message that was
new no that's a cutie as a tooltip I
figure go ahead why wouldn't there be
another sub element say you pick message
ID and then the next thing that you can
give us a list of fields that would be
included
it's fine if that might work what if
what if we don't have my Oh for
message-id all we get the whole graph
with that some point so you're saying
that LM comma all so for example if I
say reply to thread graph all comma and
then I say from and something else
you're saying that that will then label
the elements in the thread graph with
the from yep
okay sounds pretty reasonable to me okay
what have we not figured out here this
duration thing is a little weird yeah I
was going to mention that is that a
quantity or is that an interval or a
list of things I would assume these are
intervals for the duration I was
thinking it's the actual quantity its it
says it lasted three hours that's
something one cares about
I mean it's again easy rather it should
be easy to compute that once you have
the grind I wouldn't bother with that
property I mean something like how many
conversations are wrapped up in under a
day sure that's but that's a piece of
email analysis that one should be able
to do from the thread graphs sure by in
int by extracting you know the dates on
the thread graphs yeah we had a number
of a number of points on the live stream
here um okay
let's see uh someone's asking for
sentiment analysis of these you can
absolutely do that
but I don't think it should be built
into this you just use classifier with
sentiment analysis um okay
so comments um so uh salim hue is
pointing out emails are a causal network
yes it's really an amusing fact i mean
as i say now that we have that hammer
everything as a nail um okay wait a
minute
oh my gosh that's a horrifying point if
you forwarded the same email two times
to two different people it would
essentially make a graph a branch pair
an entanglement that's an interesting
question does this graph so in this
graph every node is a message ID in the
references graph is that just a single
way so there could be different
labelings there could be different tags
of the edges saying how the reference
happened you see what i'm saying it
could be the reply to reference or it
could be afforded reference so arguably
we should tag the edges but is it a
forwarded reference if it's not a reply
T reference it I'm not sure that we have
a reliable way of saying this thing was
forwarded well fair enough but at least
we can say it was a reply to we can say
and anything else could be a tagged a
separately tagged edge that says this is
simply a reference not a reply to think
it's a reference link by the way the
linking when you do this make sure we
reference transitive closure because
that's clearly going to be relevant to
an understanding these sure I think
that's interesting about this is that
even on your machine it's not
necessarily going to be in the same M
box because when you forward the message
unless you are one of the recipients
it's going to show up in your sent
folder not your inbox fine
so these message IDs may point often to
who-knows-where and we may not be able
to retrieve this additional information
and when it's a forward that is almost
always the case
but again I think for instance Gmail
shows them in the same thread in your
inbox even if it's forwarded well Gmail
kind of combines you sent in your inbox
together yeah okay there's some other
points here um Brian is pointing out
really need to support connecting to
Microsoft Outlook what is the story with
that
is that for import or mail receiver
function again no I assume that's for
mail connect mail connected right which
is a different thing from this this is
this is you've got the M box and you are
gulping the whole thing down as an
import right so I don't know I think
there's a different team working on mail
connect right I know the status of okay
at the same time like when you're an
Outlook you've already connected to some
server you should you should just IMAP
connect to that server
Roberto that like means well maybe
there's something weird about its IMAP
protocol but that's a that's a different
issue I think we should let's find out
but that's Devon maybe you can go find
that out from Fahim or whoever is
involved in that actual mail connect
thing yes make sense okay um according
to the spec forwarding should only set
the recent fields but doesn't specify
any behavior for the referencing field
ok says physically twitching um
interesting I mean the problem with
email is there are all these standards
but people don't follow them right um
and I think maybe what we should do okay
this recent field which I don't know
about in the email I just forwarded okay
because that's okay but but okay so
people are pointing out we should look
at the RFC 2822 and 52:26
and we should do that I have a I have a
very bad feeling that it's one of these
cases where there is a standard and
nobody follows it this is one of those
cases I am quite familiar with the
standard and they just don't people just
don't follow it right great um okay so a
question from Brian should there be a
property there's a count of the number
of attachments I think we have that
don't we do we not have a count of
number of attachments has attachments
attachment lists such it's a good
suggestion attachment count as a
reasonable thing to have if you scroll
down we don't have it we don't appear to
have as attachments you have a jump in
yeah it should have just been message
count honestly attachment character yeah
I'm sorry well let's say there is you
just you just got to the table that said
attachment l related elements if you
scroll just a bit more okay sorry
right length of those right so it might
be nice to have an attachment count
easier dad um okay physically is saying
when resent must fields are used the
resent from and resent date fields must
be sent the resent message ID should be
sent okay so the basic question is
resent as opposed to resent which will
be spelled exactly the same way the the
resent is the way that that according to
the RFC's forwarding should be done is
that what you believe to be the case yes
it's just I haven't seen it in practice
once yet great let's see if anybody
follows the standard um all right well
so I think what we've got here doesn't
seem foolish um I mean maybe we should
have something which if we you know
which insists on this recent thing but
the problem is everybody's going to be
frustrated because it's not gonna be
what they actually see in real life um
okay Steve is pointing out if you want
outlook 365 not really outlook anymore
nobody runs their own Outlook server if
they can avoid it
and they can do IMAP or SMTP right um oh
gosh outlook with some servers use of
proprietary X 400 protocol Wow
um what if it isn't
attachment but a Google Drive link based
attachment we now have Google Drive I
mean that's an interesting thing how do
those get represented are there you are
eyes when it when it points to a Google
Drive entry the do you understand what
I'm asking I mean is it it's Google
Drive just does it refer to it because
we now have external this external
storage support Google Drive we support
Google Drive in
in the cloud right but is it supported
by the external storage mechanism
anybody no wrong set people in this
meeting
um can we find out the answer to that
because because we we must have support
for this now because we have it for
cloud files um okay I think we're done
with this um with this email section I'm
hoping um let me save this in the right
place here
Devon um should i I just checked on the
drive thing and it's just basically
appending a URL to the end of the
message body okay so is that something
we can decode or is that something that
um um we can look for docs.google.com in
the message body but this technically
isn't an attachment and our elements are
actually referring to fields that have a
Content disposition which these do not
so they are not attachments okay I
understand so this is something which is
part of natural email understanding
basically it's a thing in the email
which is a separate an interesting thing
which actually we should should have as
a topic at p.m. at the summer school is
here um natural email understanding I
made myself a note um it's something
that we've we've danced around a bunch
of times and I know we've done a bunch
of projects on this but okay let's try
and let's try and nail a couple of other
things here um okay
do we have any more we needed to talk
about right now for email it sounds like
we have a path forward on this yes yes
yeah definitely do you need us for the
rest of the meeting don't think so thank
you very much okay yeah bye okay so
these are two functions that we started
working on a few months ago and now they
are ready so we need to take a look okay
so um
well what do you want me to go in and
doggy tools yes there are future ice
[ __ ] so these are for 12 - okay
fold while today the main thing here was
these additional arguments to control
how many additional more or less right
so reminding ourselves what this does so
far well you know is that really the
best first example the difficult thing
because it actually has to you know this
is the life of procedural programming it
is not symbolic what the thing returns
that is you know what this is doing is
saying I mean if I did this with an
ordinary fold right what would I do here
I would say ordinary fold and then I
would say here just fold list of this if
I'm not mistaken okay will be that and
what you're doing is that you say I want
to terminate the fold early no I think
it'd be useful to people to see this to
see this thing here a fold list and then
fold while after that because I think
that makes it less obscure what's going
on yeah so we have the same examples in
follow our list but yeah it's pretty
worth repeating them here which same
examples in in the page of for wide list
no I understand I understand that point
I'm just saying I'm saying that to see
what fold list does without the
termination condition it would seem
useful to me but I see I see fault right
but I think you have to say fold list
cuz otherwise nobody can see what's
going on because it's a fold it's gonna
go down to this so it's gonna be
completely obscure so what what you're
talking about is what happens after the
termination condition in other words can
I terminate on one or is there a way to
terminate at one exactly yes so that's
the these additional arguments that for
a while has and for what list so nest 1
ok so first it's the function the list
the test
so we have like fold we have the the
natural version separating the seed from
the second arguments and then the case
in which we met I say okay fine okay and
then the for argument case has a test
then there's a fifth argument horrifying
that oh boy that's that's how far back
to look for the test exactly because the
test may be looking for comparisons
between one element and the previous one
like yes I understand okay returns the
result after applying F an extra n times
after test fails okay so you're saying
if I say minus one here if I say fold
while it should be enough to do this one
okay I would say did we put it back in
system context mmm good question I can't
remember but you think it's in the
prototype builder you don't think it's
on the prototype build if it's not it's
in okay
so now what you're saying is fold while
list of this thing here
and then it needs an extra argument for
integer Q okay that's that so now if I
put if I say now I'm gonna say I want
just one I'm only gonna look at one
elements at a time and I say minus one
okay cool
yeah that's nice and if I now say if I
say eighteen here what's it gonna do
okay so it's gonna go up to a max it's
an up to of 18 basically and if I say
minus 12 here okay seems fine and if I
say is there a way to go oh that's crazy
yeah that's fine
I mean that's fine so so minus 4 or
something would just give me that okay
looks fine to me anything else to
discuss with fold well so there's the
same page effectively for a full word
list
okay sounds good all right let's move on
okay
echo timing and quiet echo yes these are
two functions that iya has written and
they follow echo and here we have
examples of these are screenshots for
notebook and for the terminal okay by
the way I had a complaint about echo in
parallel kernels does anybody know the
answer to that issue we discussed at
some point the change to a Unicode
Guillemette and I think you changed that
right yes all right probably I mean
except it gives the kernel name doesn't
it and does it do it
did you check it in a parallel
environment yeah so as the kernel name
and then both should support some kind
of monitoring we agree that's a bigger
story and it isn't finished
um that's going to be a separate
discussion in fact people I think next
week we have the giant progress
monitoring summit meeting which I guess
will live stream so um
we're talking about the progress in
progress
so to speak monitoring um okay let's go
back here so this is echo fine oh this
is echo with a koala mate do are we
pretty confident that guala maze will be
supported in all these environments that
we're not going to end up with some
crazy you know percent you know one half
weirdo thing here has the world become
modern enough that every reasonable
environment you know power shells and
all this kind of thing support Unicode I
don't know we can ask fine I I think we
should make sure that we understand I
think look to my mind one of the things
we should probably have is a
compatibility list which don't think we
have actually on our giant compatibility
page right so if you go um to wherever
it is um if you go to this giant page
the compatibility and connectivity page
right we list many many things but I
don't think we've ever thought to list
shells but we're compatible with and
that might be a good thing to inventory
because that way right that way we're
going to know whether that's gonna fail
make sense I think that's a cue ASU um
okay so what you're showing me is the
formatting it why does the label go
after the goal um I guess that's right
yes so that's what we do for it
distinguish different necklace okay and
that's really a unicode character that
clock as a unicode character okay cool
okay so now echo timing yours so echo
timing is echoing I see I see fine
yeah so echo timing is something that
you can put wrapping around some some
operation can I run it here okay so
basically what you're saying is if I say
unread page
okay one two paws three paws one five
yeah I mean the more interesting case is
where I have something where I just
insert echo timing as you know as a pure
insertion there if I'm making sense not
a like we do with echo so much so often
right scroll down to neat examples
this is by the way messed up the
formatting of this page but yeah right
so this is an example you came up with
last time we discussed what is it I mean
oh I see it's the thing where you're
getting will there's all kinds of
formatting issues here right we haven't
added this to the style sheets for
jockey tools yet until we get approval
okay but so you're saying in this case
here you're saying that this would give
this is going to give the sub echo sub
timings here yeah that's pretty cool
is there any value in having some kind
of mouse over or click thing here
probably not I don't know what it could
do but but I mean just to be clear that
this would be echo echo timing if I'm
not mistaken this would work right yes I
can just insert echo timing and probably
the example should look like that just
because it's a convenient way to show
how you can do it okay looks good
alright any more okay what is quiet echo
so that's a new thing which we can use
to eliminate the echo results so I see
that says that's an anti acha so that's
a quiet that is a a but now what kind of
echoes will it quiet does it quiet all
Aiko's or does it slide only echoes um
every echo echo function echo timing um
okay
complaining that echo was implemented on
I don't think so I think that that is
what you are asking for is echo function
you're saying that echo you're
complaining that the operator form of
echo that it needs okay right now echo
the issue is is there an operator form
of echo that allows you to give the
label and the answer is echo right now
has an X / followed by label followed by
label but the operator form here is if
you just give a single thing it's that I
mean there's a certain argument that we
should have an echo label which does
have the feature that you can give a
label here and that it's operator form
is like that I mean the alternative
obviously is to say operator applied
echo but that's kind of grotesque I mean
this would work right but I'm not
mistaken
or you could do echo function in specify
the label comma identity that's ugly
I think we should consider this eco
label thing because I agree that this
would be super useful
I mean I'd use it all the time so if I
have multiple echos to be able to
specify which one is which what do you
guys think about that I mean because I I
do use eco who's labour smart because
many so I think we should let's let's
look at that okay and it's equivalent to
operator reply to echo with a label um
so uh let's see we should for echo
timing sorry what option for echo timing
has a method option wish to have a label
what do you say no sorry we had a few
days ago and I think in repeated timing
we should repeat we should do that again
and have a method option that says what
kind of timing it is right so we're
considering perhaps this is a discussion
for sec the possibility of having a
timing function rather than method in in
the same way that you have a distance
function wow that's a good idea it's a
good idea that's a good idea okay we
have an LCC meeting coming right up in
fact and we need to switch to that other
stream here um let me just see this
question about levels of echo okay let's
just talk about quiet echo and then we
go to them the other meeting um so you
I mean this is basically sensible there
are questions about exactly whether it
should have second arguments and things
I mean it's clearly going to be used
mostly as like this quiet echo of a
thing and I don't think we can yeah I
mean we might want a second argument
saying what it quiets but I think that's
a luxury um all right listen we have to
go I think some of you are also involved
in the LCC meeting some of you're not
and right for folks on the livestream we
are switching over to a different stream
for our language completeness and
consistency meeting and I don't know
what its agenda is I'm about to find out
we're missing date select which we will
do next time um okay great thanks guys
so I hope to see people on the
livestream in our other in our other
session here great see y'all soon okay